all right this is I forgot already power
animal god I just looked at two okay so
this episode where a Finn is having a
roof party and he comes across a bunch
of gnomes dressed as a guy and they want
to use his energy to power their boss
occult beneath the machine there what it
was really funny to I care I was like
this machine that turns the world upside
down so now the gnomes will be oh no no
no the beneathaverse name was a place
and then the machine is gonna turn
everything upside down so the gnomes
will now be on top and Jake forgets
about Finn
or he kind of keeps remembering and
keeps forgetting and eventually he gets
to this place where he's partying with a
bunch of cloud people and just this
floating pretty detailed wolf head with
a backwards hat and because the wolf
likes and he gives him the power to
locate Finn and he saves the day and
then they go eat cinnamon roll cinnamon
buns cinnamon bun excuse me
I get the you know maybe it's spelled
roll but pronounced bun and maybe I'm
just saving the traditional cinnamon way
in this world I wouldn't doubt it it
could totally be possible okay so a
couple things about this one first what
some of these designs really like the
the wolf head I thought was I just loved
that he had so much detail yeah that was
great
ah the two the two girls with the water
hair I thought that was great of a one
actually went to like sort of a
waterfall on the bottom as I I thought
that was so that's really cool oh yeah
um and it seems like in any series there
has to sort of be like I'm sure there's
a name for it to me there's a trope
percent but like a torture episode you
ever notice that just with a show that's
out long enough there has to be like an
episode where like a person goes through
a great deal of pain like in one
location so I like the saw episode or
something I don't remember that in like
full house their family matters no no
the full house is what they show those
people being tortured you see gotcha man
so where's yes
material for it so but yeah I just think
it like you know whatever Star Trek or
my x-men or something like that there's
always like an episode just where
someone's going through like a lot of
pain or something
and I guess this was Finn's and I I
don't want to say like I like them cuz I
sound sick and like I'm into torture
porn or something but there is something
about like there is something about
those episodes where it's just I don't
know maybe they just create a media
drama you want to see the person get out
you want to see them not suffer and like
what it's over he just like wow they
survived something really tough and
they're gonna be stronger for it or
maybe they just go eat cinnamon bun but
oh so this has got fins up and so for
that I got it I felt there's a scene
where he's like he's not supposed to
think anything is out charge since
machine and he has a fantasy that he
gets out and he's super muscular and
everything um and it's all a fantasy and
I felt legitimately bad try think of
what else the the owner bit that I it's
got some really odd but I really liked
is that they have a roof party and after
the party is done it's sort of like pans
up dissolves and pans back down he
seemed just sort of cleaning for a bit
and putting things away and they just
even the pajamas going to say and it's
like no music no talking or anything
it's just like a few seconds of quiet I
don't know why I really liked it just
felt a atmospheric um well the show is
so spastic so full of color and sound
and all that stuff it's one of those
moments where you see it you're like
wait a minute
they are kind of normal he's a normal
kid or they're in a normal house and
well at normal they do have to clean up
they do have to get ready for bed
instead it's fancy it little seems like
that just make a moment or if they make
a world seem a little bit more real
that's one of the reasons I mean a lot
of people are like filler but it's like
I really like just those little quiet
moments you know just a moment or
character can just serve you care to eat
it just for a few seconds oh so I can't
like that I know it's um I only know
feels like intentional maybe it just
need like a segue but but I really like
that oh and
yeah I guess has the torture episodes go
well people don't like this was fine you
know and had the okay and I I actually
legitimately laughed at the Goblin with
the missing left arm and left leg Joe I
thought that was actually funny I think
that's maybe that maybe my sense of
humor is finally just be derailed by
watching this show yeah yeah just that
well pounds of money Joseph why
so yeah just a good episode silence
who's ever phone that was never played
drop ball with you again Oh
will you get my gift by the way please I
have a gift for you my friend
are you aware that we're still doing a V
log at me as she talks now you're giving
me a gift is that what we're at a store
and so we're at some store and I found
this button for you I bet I got one of
my own which has wizard powers on it and
it has been in Jake but I found
oh it's tree trunk focus is that God
focus Davey you know what it is Oh God
dear sexy tree trunks sorry it's not
sexy a while now looks like I'm like you
know fighting for the tree trunks cause
or something like that like raise tree
trunks awareness you see my tree trunks
pin bracelet weirdness of tree trunks we
won't bring her back actually probably
comes back from what I hear but ya know
just solid episode fun torture know what
I liked about it was is that in a lot of
those episodes where someone is being
tortured or whatever when they get out
they beat everyone up and then they feel
good for beating everyone up this one he
breaks out and what was his happiest
moment when Jake showed up and they just
started hugging and saying I missed you
I missed you like to me that was
actually kind of almost touching that
he's not concerned about anything else
other than being with his best friend
isn't everyone kind of already beaten up
didn't Jake just like destroy everybody
that way I guess they give them all the
more incentive just hit these dead
bodies fantasy oh oh yeah that said he
punches him in stuff but I just
he stops all that just when Jake shows
up and they hug yeah I do so like that
in his fancy and she imagines like he
gets out but then Jake also comes to and
it's like oh we're reunite it's like
what he really wants yeah and I guess
I'm sort of that nice friendship of the
two like us yeah I I can't stand it I
even if you got me my tree trunks
awareness pin it's pink - like you know
can't breast cancer breast cancer she
grew up and is a crystal when I heard
somewhere that actually that was
supposed to be like it was supposed to
cut yeah but you're she's yeah but okay
right ever goes um but uh yeah solid
episode you know funny lots of energy I
get just some fun designs and when they
go into that cloud world I this world
reminds me more and more of like so like
Super Mario 3 or like mario world
instead I I don't know it just it has
are that feel and I like that feel like
just anything you can kind of imagine
you know it's just so bright and
colorful and happy and fun and
adventures it just sort of exists here
and everything in have a fake yeah even
down to like everything having a face
like the hills practically have faces
that the hills have eyes no good my
original that remake I wore famous ever
done that like just have like Mario with
the hills they have like the faces in
the bag just as like the hills but yeah
solid episode good episode
anything else you got the other I like
the dancing bugs
yeah I like Jakes I can't do it but it
was like this very specific waving of
people